kind of going back a little bit more  repeating ponging over here but you know  most people Define poverty in dollars  and cents but they don't but if if if  poverty if curing poverty was nothing  more than a stimulus check then black  people among all people well you know  all of our issues would be solved right  when you when you begin to think about  all the aid and all the government money  uh you know that that certain  communities get so if money if dollars  and cents was all that was needed in  order to cure poverty then hey it'll be  you know it's simple and it would be  over because our government has has  um has given welfare to so many  different groups of people but it's more  than that right and it's a Brokenness  and culture right it's uh where where  we're bankrupt in culture and it's not  just a black thing any longer